hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be going over a game between Kasparov
and Topalov and many players have said
that this is the greatest chess game
ever played now we'll let y'all a debate
between you know if y'all think this is
the greatest game ever played but it is
Kasparov a mortal game and pretty much
all the top GM's famous players have
their own immortal game and it it's just
that it makes them considered immortal
in the chess world so Garrick is fouled
many consider the greatest chess player
to ever play the game if this is his
immortal game then I will have to say
this is probably one of the best games
ever played so with that said Garrick is
both playing the white pieces and Topal
of playing the black pieces
starts out with pani for pond d6 pawn d4
Knight f6 Knight c3 pawn to g6 and so
blob really decided that he wanted to
play the perk defense and so that's what
black is going to be playing here if you
haven't watched the video on the perk
defense and you want to get a foundation
of how the perk defense really plays out
and kind of the themes before you watch
this video definitely feel free to go
watch that but if not we'll go ahead and
continue white played Bishop to e3
Bishop to g7 fee and King's Bishop Queen
to d2 Knight you can already see from
white that he's already developed his
Knights here to c3 and his Bishop here
to e3 and once he moved his Queen to d2
his very apparent that he was looking to
castle on the Queen side a lot of times
if you're white and you develop your
light square bishop and your knight here
to possibly f3 a lot of times that will
signal that you're going to castle on
the King side but from here he's already
made way to castle on the Queen side so
that's more than likely what Kasparov
had been had in the back of his mind as
far as where he wanted to Castle black
decided to play pawn to c6 and white
played pawn to f3 nemesis in a very
aggressive line from white here and it's
probably one of the newer lines which
we've seen at top-level play in 1999
this hasn't been analyzed too much
around this time that it was played so
right away we can see that Gary Kasparov
had spent a lot of time on this opening
and you really knew what he was doing he
was trying to put
another defender on this pawn here on e4
and at the same time he was really
looking to castle on the queenside
play continued with pawn to b5 and this
is very important play right here from
black he does two things with this move
the first thing is he advances upon to
gain space on the Queen side starting to
you know push his pawns down the board
of the Queen's at the same time it
prevents a very strong move from white
why I'd really like to bring his Bishop
to c4 it's very powerful Square it's a
great square for the light square bishop
and because of this play from black on
b5 it really prevents this light square
Bishop coming to c4 and attacking this
square here on f7 so this move does
multiple things and you're going to see
this a lot in this game there's a lot of
fantastic moves that have kind of dual
roles and this is one of those dual roll
moves right here this pawn here on b5
not only advances a pawn to gain space
on the Queen side but it also keeps this
light square Bishop and you can see
later on this game this light square
bishop is pretty much pinned down to
this f1 Square and is really going to be
the last piece that white develops and
this mainly due to this pawn here on d5
play continues from here with white
bringing his Knight to e2 he realizes
that he's not going to be able to bring
his light square Bishop right away so
instead he decides that it's okay to
block off the light square bishop with
his knight here on e 2 since it's really
not a good square that he wants to bring
his light square bishop to from here
black's going to bring his Knight to d7
and why it's going to play Bishop to h6
and why does he do this well anytime you
feel can do your Bishop to the king side
is black did with his Bishop on g7 this
dark square bishop here is a very
important piece not only for this long
dark diagonal but the same time
defending this King here if the King
decides to castle on the King side now
once white plays this black pretty much
knows that he's not going to be castling
on the King side and so instead of that
he decides to go ahead and trade off
bishops and instead try to get a little
sinner dark square play in this center
so right away he knows with this queen
here on h6 he's not going to be castle
on the Queen side so he decides to
really focus on the dark squares in the
center knowing that he's probably going
to be castling on the Queen side play
continues with black bringing his Bishop
to b7 continuing his development of his
minor pieces and White's going to play
pawn to a3 and this is a very important
move because it's a prophylactic move
kind of waiting to see what black does
white eventually wants to castle on the
Queen side but this is a very important
move if white wore to first castle on
the Queen side black could come in with
his pawn to b4 and disrupt really what
White's plans are white would be forced
to move this night before he castles and
that's not really what he wants to do so
instead as most top-level GM's do they
always find the right times to play a
prophylactic move and this is exactly
that time where you
is a three kind of a waiting move to see
what black doesn't at the same time
preventing black from coming in and
playing b4 right after this canceling on
the queenside so from here black plays
pawn to e5 again in the perk defense or
any hyper modern defense once you really
develop your minor pieces you're really
trying to attack the center can be
center with your minor pieces and then
later on you want to counter attack or
attack and gain center control with your
pawn so that's exactly what to blob is
doing here he has all his minor pieces
developed and now he's starting to
attack and try to stake claim to the
center as we talked about from here why
it's going to castle on the Queen side
that's what he wanted to in the first
place but again he wanted to play his a3
first and blacks gonna from now play
Queen to e7 now after you develop your
minor pieces you do want to get your
Queen involved if you don't have a
specific place to get your Queen
involved you always want to develop it
to the middle of the board so that
wherever you may need your queen she can
hop over you know very quickly if you
you know put your Queen to one side the
board and she's needed on the other side
of the board a lot of times a very good
player will block off the Queen and
you're pretty much left playing on one
side of the board without your most
powerful Pete Soto blob knows this and
he brings its Queen to e7 can hop over
the board where the Queen needs to and
at the same time getting ready to blob
wants to to castle on the Queen side
connect his rooks and his development
will be complete
now from here White's going to play keen
to be won again another prophylactic
move white doesn't want to start to
attack on one side and then just have
black you know castle to the other side
or start to move to the other side so
it's kind of a waiting move playing King
to b11 it's allowing him to get a little
bit more safety for his king but the
same time kind of waiting to see what
blacks going to do and black decided to
bring his pawn to a6 and this is done
for a few reasons and one of the reasons
eventually black would like to push his
pawn from c6 to c5
right now his LightSquared bishop is not
in the game he eventually would like to
get into the game he doesn't need to
right now but later on it is on this
long diagonal and he would like to use
it since it is a powerful piece but as
soon as he moves pawn to c5 then his b5
pawn will be hanging so this a six move
is kind of a you know move getting ready
for the future down the road not
immediately but again you always want to
be thinking down the road so total
opposites and he knows eventually wants
to play c5 and so because of this he
needs to play a six to support this pawn
here on b5
play continues in white now brings his
knight to see one and if you analyze it
back from this position this is a very
strong move if white really looks at
this and sees what he wants to do he
really wants to get his Knights involved
his knight here on C three is
well-placed
but he'd really like to get his knight
here on e two to the best score on the
board now if you look at it where is the
best score on the board we can already
tell that blacks probably not going to
castle on the Kings side we have our
Queen to the White has the Queen here on
h6 really keeping black from castling on
the King side and so white knows this
and since black is going to be castling
on the Queen side more than likely then
white knows he wants to start moving his
minor pieces in his major pieces towards
the Queen side with that said the best
place the best square for this night
here on e2 is actually going to be a
five so what's the easiest and the best
way to get this Knight to a5
first to see one and then here to be
three and then to a fob so that's kind
of what Kasparov was thinking in the
back of his head so again if you have a
plan go ahead and start to move towards
that so his first play is night to see
one now from here blacks going to
continue with his development he castles
on the Queen side so he now has both of
his works connected and he has the rest
of his pieces developed so black in this
case is finished in development and now
it is White's turn and white now brings
his Knight to b3 again he really wants
to I this square here on a5 s we talked
about it's a fantastic square for his
night to be attacking the entire Queen
side of black now black hair decided to
capture on d4 for y'all who don't know
Topalov is a very aggressive player I've
studied quite a lot of his games because
I have a very aggressive style like him
and so took blob now that he has
developed all his pieces exactly how he
wants them he's going to start to
counter-attack he knows that you know
instinctively White has the advantage
just because they have that extra tempo
in the game and so he wants to start to
try to attack and try to play for the
win as he always does
now from here white took with d4 now a
lot of players would say why not take
with his knight on d4
especially since after you know we take
with this rook black decided to bring
his pawn to c5 again what we talked
about before playing his pawn to c5
opening up this long diagonal for this
Bishop here on d7 but if we take with
our night or if white takes with his
knight on d4 black
does not have to right away play his
pawn to c5 he can kind of wait and again
white really wants to bring his Knight
to a5 so if he wants to bring his Knight
to a5 then capturing with his his night
here on d4 is probably not the best
strategy instead because far off ops for
his rook takes on d4 and after the pawn
attacks here on d4 he brings his rook
back to d1 so that's very small as far
as why he did that but I do want to let
you know because you may have been
looking at him but man why did is far up
not take with his night on b3 he really
wants to bring his knight to 85 and if
top blob did not play this pawn to on c5
he didn't want to lose tempos bringing
his knight back to b3 and then to a5
from here black played Knight to e6
getting ready if he ever wanted to to
bring his pawn to d5 his pawn here on d6
isn't doing too much and it's kind of
hanging behind he eventually wants to
centralize this pawn here on d6 and
bring it to d5 in this 99 b6 will be a
strong defender of this pawn if he ever
does bring it to d5 now from here white
had to make a decision Amy's decided to
bring his pawn to g3 now a lot of
players including myself would want to
quickly finish development and bring
their Bishop to e2 and that seems like a
logical move but because Bob was looking
down the road and he said you know what
let's bring my pawn to g3
because I want to develop my Bishop to
h3 and really
way this long lights were diagonal and
put a lot of pressure on this black King
so although it's going to take him two
moves to finish his development his
light square bishop is going to be on
the exact square that he wants it to and
that's this square here on h3 where it
can you know take this long diagonal and
attack the Queen side of black here so
after g3 here blacks gonna play King to
b8 getting his King out of the way once
the bishop come to h3 and white first is
going to bring his Knight to a5 now
again this is the plan that can spar off
one of the entire game and so now he
brings that plan to fruition and black
is going to bring his Bishop back to a8
this long diagonal Bishop for black to
pull up does not want to get rid of it
right away and why it's okay with that
he has a knight here very nicely placed
on e5 it's going to put a lot of
pressure on black the rest the game it's
going to be really hard for black to get
rid of that Knight anytime soon so from
here White's going to continue with his
development with Bishop to h3 this is
the exact square that conspire wanted
his Bishop here on h3 putting a lot of
pressure on this long light square it
this long light diagonal at the same
time he has now finished his development
so it did take him a little longer to
finish his development he's connected
his rooks but at the same time his game
plan is going exactly how he wants it
black from here played pawn to d5 and
instead of taking right away
Kasparov decided to bring his Queen to
f4 and this is what really separates you
know normal players from you know
masters to GM's GM's are always looking
for the in-between move so a lot of
players would already see this pawn to
d5 and say you know how can I recapture
and start to calculate and top players
are always looking for what's the
in-between moving in between move here
was Queen to f4 he can take a look at
this capturing later on but right away
he wants to bring his Queen to the
action and check the king now the King
only has one loops you can see you can't
come to c7 c8 because the Queen and
Bishop they can't come to b7 because
they're not here his only move is King
to a7 so already you can see why it's
really starting to put King the black
King into a tight corner here now white
chose to disregard this pawn here on d5
right away and instead centralized his
ropes as you can see White's pieces are
really in good positioning it's too
centralized rooks he has his bishop in
his LightSquared as his Queen as like to
her Bishop bearing down on this Queen
side and his Knights are very well
placed attacking the King side hurts the
King on the Queen side so from here
black decided to continue to push up his
pawn here to d4 starting to put some
pressure
and white decided to bring his Knight to
d5 and this is an amazing move because
white eventually is going to be
sacrificing a pawn so that he can open
up a huge attack against black black
decided to take with his night here on
d5 and white recaptured with his pawn on
d5 at the same time attacking the Queen
here on e7
black now brought his queen to d6 again
it was being attacked so he did need to
move it and white decided to capture and
sacrifice his rook here on d4 and this
is probably the move of the game after
Topalov took back as you can already see
cuz spa really wanted to sacrifice this
just so anytime he wanted to his queen
could come into d4 and check the king
and again all the moves that king has
black king has are very limited so he
knows that even though he gave up a rook
he really has a lot of strong attacks
but from here Kasparov found an amazing
move and he found a rook to e7 now this
is a fantastic move because the black
Queen cannot take here on his 7 if he
does then we have a mating opportunity
we can bring her white can bring his
queen to d4 after the King goes back to
b8
the Queen can come to b6 it doesn't
matter if the black bishop comes to be 7
or the Queen comes to b7 doesn't really
matter the knight here can come to c6
after the king goes back to a8 it's
going to be checkmate if instead instead
of the bishop the Queen comes here then
it's going to be even a checker a
quicker checkmate with Knight to c6 so
as you can see right away our rook here
on e7 there's nothing that the King here
on a 7 can do besides move to b6 now if
we go back a few moves after the rook
comes here to d4 sacrificing the rook
here conspire I've actually said that
the best move for black would have been
to bring his King to be 6 because parvum
self said there's no good way for white
to continue here but top lob in the game
took over an hour to find well not
really fine but to calculate out that
taking on d4 would be the best situation
obviously he saw that white did have a
lot of fighting options but over an hour
of thinking taupe a lob one of the best
players in the game decided that you
know what I'm going to take this
sacrifice and I think I can fight my way
back being up so much in material so
that's exactly what his father wanted to
do and he brought his rook to e7
and then after the king came to b6 like
we talked about before the Queen took on
d4 and that's exactly why this rook
sacrifice on d4 was important because it
got the pawn from C 5 out of the way so
that we can check
and from here black decided to take the
night here on a five it was kind of
forced there's no realtor square for
black to go to and white decided to
continue to push with this pawn to b4
now again there's not many other moves
that white black can do here so he
brings his King to a four now luckily
Kasparov thought this game out because
if you just look at this board right
away yes the king is in a lot of trouble
for black but as you can see black is up
quite a bit of material in this game but
conspire being a great player that he is
he saw all the lines in the game and he
realized that he had a lot of not only
mating chances but the same time he had
a lot of attacking lines where he could
make up that material later on in the
game because of the vulnerability of the
black king so from here why decided to
bring his queen to c3 and she can see
Kasparov is threatening made here he can
bring his Queen to b3 so black has to do
something easiest thing for black to do
here is take on d5 it's kind of forced
there's no other way for black really to
get out of this and from here why
decided to bring his rook to a7 at the
same time rook here on a7 is threatening
mate here after it takes on a6 that
would be checkmate so black is forced to
bring his Bishop to b7 to attack and
defend this pawn here on a6
and from here white can take with his
rook here on b7 now again why it is
still threatening the square here on C
on b3 with checkmate so black decides to
bring his queen to c4 and from here
white takes on f6 so right away we can
are to see the whites taken off this
night and this Bishop off the board so
although just a few moves go it look
like black goes up a ton of material now
we see it blacks only up just a few
points and material from here black
decided to take this pawn here on e3 and
now the queen is going to come into the
action with queen cakes on a6 now after
the King takes on b4 White has a
brilliant move here and he plays pawn to
c3 sacrificing this pawn at the same
time basically saying you know what I'm
going to leave my king vulnerable
because I'm gonna make your King come to
c3 and I'm just going to attack an
attack an attack and I'm sure he thought
about this move for a long time and
thought about all the variations of what
he could come up with as you'll see it
came to fruition II keep in mind that
the black Queen cannot take on c3
because from here
Kasparov could just take with this Queen
and then when the king came to the a
file the route could swing over and the
only move to stop it would be to bring
Queen over and it's checkmate from there
so Chris Bob knew this and he knew that
you know breeze pawn to c3 would force
the King to come to c3 and take now he
could obviously come to a different
square like c5 but again he would be out
in the open and he would lose even
quicker than he did so tow blob decided
to take on c3 and conspire I've played
Queen to a-1 at the same time as you can
see he's setting this up so he can take
this rook here on h8 if he wants to
after this King moves but King comes
down to d2 and Queen comes to B to D 1
and then the bishop comes to f1 this is
a fantastic move because the Queen
cannot take this fish upon f1 if it does
then the Queen comes the c2 and after
the King moves then then the rook here
on e7 that's good game Queen can
obviously check it but it's going to be
checkmate so this is the fantastic move
that cos para found his Bishop here on
h3 that was attacking the king now the
king is down here on d1 and now he's
going to get his Bishop involved here
and attack this Queen so Topalov came
down and played rook to d2
and because 5 played rook to d7
basically saying you're not going to be
taking my queen because I'm pinning your
rook down to your king and so tope bluff
was forced to take the rook here on d7
and that leaves the Queen here on c4 for
the taking and after that's taken then
Kasbah takes the rook on h8 as we talked
about before
and from here Topol off can pretty much
resigned the game
he's down quite a bit in material and
White has a queen he can pretty much
just run over the board the game did go
a few moves further on but then once
Topal I've realized that he's playing
Kasparov and cos Park has a queen he
went ahead and resigned in this
situation so I really enjoyed studying
this game reading a lot of different
people's commentary on a lot of the
different moves and I learned quite a
bit so hopefully y'all learned quite a
bit as well
and these are two of the greatest chess
minds that have ever played so I do feel
like a lot of their moves you can learn
from because there's so much meaning in
every move that they make so hopefully
you guys enjoyed this video hopefully
you guys enjoyed my commentary if you
haven't already please subscribe and I
will see you guys in the next video
thanks for watching